hi everyone my name is Cameron chambers
and this is cameras never seen and as
promised today I am watching Hot Fuzz I
love his stuff
I just watched Shaun of the Dead last
week for the first time and absolutely
loved it if this film is anything in
that kind of direction I'm all for it
I wrote y'all know what time it is give
it those Hot Fuzz predictions 20 minutes
and then the GARP guy ahh
let's do it obviously I loved it
just like Shaun of the Dead they both
have their own sense of like seriousness
and it's just it kind of comes out of
nowhere you're just expecting it to be a
comedy just face value and and it's not
and there's just so much more first
thing I wrote down in my notes is Wow
different character Batman such a
different character between the two
movies it's amazing in shot of Adeje was
kind of like this dud kind of lost
character and in this he just like this
badass kind of hard-ass police cop
officer oh by the way Martin Freeman
makes another appearance in this again a
very small appearance but I love it
nonetheless most of my notes are just
like oh that was clever Wow clever jokes
hilarious jokes funny joke
this was just filled to the brim with
perfect comedy clever and subtle but
then I need some not so so but so really
amazing things with the crossword right
up front when he goes and checks into
the hotel she calls him a fascist I
think and he calls her a hag then later
it comes up again they're actually
calling each other those names so funny
and clever and being camera shavers
think Hot Fuzz is so funny clever
film critic of the year so simon Pegg's
character Nicholas angel is a London cop
best of the best and they transfer him
to a small little village because he
kind of showing them up and making the
all the other cops was bad for a while
there's just a lot of small town joke
happening he goes to the pub even
younger kids and a teen drinking at the
pub and he like goes up to them with his
badge what's your birthday and just
arrests a bunch of you know adolescents
young boys and Simon Skinner who owns
the store in the town comes up to him
and says I'm a slasher all prices weird
his voice is sexy a creepy eyes that
mustache yet at one point the entire
force is eating cake just feels very
small town and then it fits you so good
I wonder if people are gonna bring this
up in the prediction the police chief
chief the police the police chief some
police chief's some Danny is now
Nicholas angels partner and Danny loves
cotton it's just like have you seen
lethal weapon no die hard no bad boys -
no look look same same same I thought I
hard for this but you know it was for
work so not much is happening in this
town is basically what I'm trying to say
in what's being portrayed on screen and
they're going after this kid who robbed
some biscuits from a grocery store
there's a great callback where Nicholas
is about to jump over fences and Danny's
like what are you doing
what's the matter Danny never taken a
shortcut before exit starts jumping over
fences and then Danny tries it just
plows into the fence and it's actually
hilarious like laugh out loud so funny
and this is ripped out in all caps what
the hell where did the axe murderer come
from again
I love the twist of this it starts
opposites like funny bunny hops silly
movie and then it gets real like real
things I don't think I'm used to that in
my like silly comedies over here in
America
you get one or the other how many or
substance is few and far between that
you get all of it like this and this is
like a whole trilogy of these three
movies that are all just so good you
know it's really ramping up I love Nick
Frost and this movie kind of a clumsy
guy who you know the I think others are
mostly just taking care of him and it's
that same kind of vibe from the first
movie but the first movie it was just
kind of like why are they putting up
with him whereas in here he's really
kind he's a good friend and she just
happened to not be the best cop but he's
learning so much from Nicholas angel
it's amazing it's so good have I yet
have I mentioned that it's good yet and
I said that it's so good that would be
uh gore and Billy a son the challenge
really now getting to Nick and the
bullying from the police force who don't
believe him and just a small-town vibe
and the killings no one will even look
into it all and all of a sudden he's
attacked and he's attacked by the arc
guys what I call him did he's a big guy
that just says he got all the time
pretty one-dimensional character and
through this attack he finds out that
most of the town is actually in on
murder
he goes and he follows them to this old
castle where they're all chanting in
black robes with candles and
walkie-talkies ah small town charm the
Nicholas angel obviously confronts all
of the townspeople and I would like to
recap that confrontation right now
you're under arrest so great you're good
you killed him for being in bed after
the greater good the way you kilter for
having an annoying laugh so greater good
but you killed him for having an
obnoxious own the greater good you
killed him then they have bad grammar
the greater good oh the police chases in
on this crusty jugglers
I should make a video where I don't have
any cuts and you guys just see me going
like this a million times because it's
that that's real entertainment right
there Wow Wow he decides to gear up with
like lots of guns and a horse and he
straight up air kicks an 80 year old
woman and then he just goes around to
the town square and starts dueling with
all of these senior citizen to run she
finally gets all of the police force on
his side and Danny's with him and they
go to take down Skinner and there's this
hilarious scene between Danny and an
angel Nicholas Hamilton Christmas Chris
angels in this as well did you know he
is Danny's like where's the yard guy
Nicholas is like in the freezer well did
you say cool ah no I didn't say anything
well that's a shame
the police chief's Skinner are in a car
and then Danny and Nicholas angel are in
a car and at some point they pick up the
Swan they spin Philippa turns into this
giant Godzilla reenactment between
Skinner and Angel and it's so brilliant
but there's one person left from the old
person's brigade who decides to come in
and take care of Nicholas angel and he
shoots at him and Danny jumps in front
of him and gets shot and then there's a
giant explosion from the sea mine
because of course and it's like what
it's dead dead what and the no no he's
not dead and it's kind of perfect this
bill was kind of perfect
Tamra's grade Hot Fuzz kind of perfect
he is has rapidly become my favorite
director of all times
I just think he is incredible it's
really engaging work and editing and
filming you will not see the HOA cult
coming and will be genuinely sad when
the flower lady dies yes also I really
thought that it was going to turn out to
be the human statue was doing it all
because they were so concerned with it
was like how funny would have used that
he was like actually a threat also
hairflip girl don't forget
I have been so forgetful about hair flip
3 sleep thank you for the beautiful
reminder that Bush - you ain't seen bad
boys - one you'll like it more than
Shaun of the Dead
maybe maybe you'll find the use of sound
effects act and the jump cuts great for
showing a passage of time yes I think
that Edgar Wright does an incredible job
with cuts his I mean his editing just in
general but but yeah his use of music
and n sound and just quick cuts are just
so engaging and good and yet awesome you
will remember to flip your hair for the
greater good very unlikely but you'll
get to Aaron a Aaronson joke the first
time around I don't get that just
thought it was a funny name why I don't
get it Cate Blanchet words in this I
think I missed a lot in simple I think I
need to rewatch this like immediately
cancel all my plans today I cleared my
schedule that was so much flipping fun
I'm probably going to do a poll on my
Twitter this week asking if I should
just finish out the series and do
world's end or if I should make me take
a break but follow me on Twitter to see
that or just to tweet out any fun things
that I probably missed in the film thank
you so much for watching I will see you
all next week
for the greater good the greater good
[Music]
[Applause]
you